There's something really surprising about these age distributions, which is these ones are clustered
very close to 18 whereas these are all over the place really far from 18 in most cases.
So can we calculate this somehow?
I would say the mode, the median, or the mean don't really capture the spread of the data.
What does calculate the spread is called the variance.
Now we will compute the variance of the data, and the very first trick you apply is,
we normalized these sequences by subtracting the mean from each data item.
So in the case of the friends, if we subtract 18 from 17 we get -1, 1, 0, -1, 1.
If we subtract 18 from these data sequence, we get -11, 20, -14, 5, and 0.
If you compute the mean of these two sequences, then you find the mean in both cases is 0
and that's bigger the work and the reason is by subtracting the mean from every single data item
we took it out of the equation and we arrived at 0.
But what's now really interesting is, that these numbers are much
closer to zero than these numbers over here.
So, the spread over here is much larger.
Now you might think in computing the variance,
you just add up all these values and measure up the spread, but the truth is it doesn't work.
If you add them up, they are actually 0. So we have to add up something else.
What's commonly added up are the squares of those values. The squares here are 1, 1, 0, 1, 1.
Whereas over here, they're 121, 400, 196, 25, 0.
For the variance, we sum the squares of all these numbers and normalize that.
But the squares are not taken of the original data but taken off the original data minus the mean
and we're going to write that as Greek letter over here, µ.
Do me a favor and try to compute the variance for the first sequence,
which you obtained by adding those squares over here and dividing them by 5.